This video is sponsored by MUBI
-I'm reliving the same day over and over
Groundhog day, today
In the greek myth of Sisyphus, Sisyphus is granted immortality
But he must spend eternity rolling a stone up a hill
A difficult and thankless task and every time he reaches the top the stone comes rolling back down
Unable to die, Sisyphus is destined to a life of laboring without any hope of escape or measure of progress
If we strip away the future with its consequences for our actions
-Don't you worry about cholesterol, lung cancer, love handles?
-I don't worry about anything anymore
Leaving us with only our own existence and how we live each day
Can we find meaning in life?
Existential philosopher Albert Camus saw that as the absurd plight of humanity
Stuck toiling in a godless meaningless universe or labor ultimately amounting to nothing
In his essay the myth of Sisyphus
Camus uses the greek legend as a metaphor for our lives. So does Groundhog Day
What would you do?
If you were stuck in one place
And every day was exactly the same and nothing that you did mattered
Now that sums it up for me
And so does the 2020 Andy Samberg rom-com Palm Springs
Good day so far?
Today, tomorrow, yesterday. It's all the same
It's a metaphor that might feel especially appropriate right now when many of us have been stuck at home on our own for
Days
Or weeks. I don't know my sense of time is a little fuzzy
Living days that might feel more mundane and repetitive
Watch out for that first step. It's a doozy
In Groundhog Day, Phil Connors plays a sort of cosmic game stuck reliving the same day in a town he hates surrounded by people
he hates. He despises everything around him. Upon realizing his new fate
What the hell
He moves from the pursuit of hedonism to suicidal despair
To apathetically accepting his fate
I wake up every day right here
right in Punxsutawney
And it's always february 2nd
And there's nothing I can do about it
And finally to personal
transformation and finding meaning in virtuous selfless living
By the end of the film
He is freed from his prison, but he opts largely to continue living in the world he's been trapped in
Let's live here
A changed man, the town and people around him now look completely different.
It's one of those
infinite time loop situations you might heard about
That I might have heard about. Yeah.
It's into this world that not only contains groundhog day
But it's countless offspring that Palm Springs arrives
Palm Springs acknowledges its predecessor.
Maybe it's a karma thing. What is
Yeah, what if it's like
To get out of this
You have to be selfless and then you're free. Oh my god
What if life just keeps going for everyone else here, but not you and me until we've earned our way out
But it has little interest in rehashing the same ground
Instead it seeks to find something new and interesting in the concept by making some critical changes
Palm springs brings other people into the loop.
Guess you followed me
But this changes surprisingly little about the philosophical implications of the time loop world
With other people there
you can measure your internal change against those people
You got here. That's all that matters
But if you really want to know someone deeper it does matter
But still without a future, what does that change even mean?
I'm not gonna see my kids grow up
Never gonna walk a little livvy down the aisle
By bringing other people into the loop, Palm Springs strengthens the concept as a metaphor for our own lives
becomes not just about an individual's isolated search for
meaning but a community search for meaning in the face of a seemingly absurd world
It doesn't matter that everything resets and people don't remember. We remember, we have to deal with the things that we do
Oh my God, cry me a river, Nyles
And just like people in real life take different approaches to finding meaning so do the characters stuck in the loop in palm springs
The universe henceforth without a master seems to him neither sterile nor futile
The struggle itself towards the heights is enough to fill a man's heart
One must imagine Sisyphus happy
For Camus we must embrace the absurdity of life.
Wait, stop!
There's a bomb in the cake
Don't worry
I used to be a bomb guy
Everyone stand back
Camus says if we accept its meaninglessness and live passionately we can find happiness
In Palm Springs, this is essentially what we find Nyfles trying to do.
You just have to find peace
You know
In groundhog day for a time we find Phil Connors living this way
But I don't think either film ultimately accepts Camus idea
In Groundhog Day Phil eventually accepts the absurdity of his new life
But mere acceptance isn't enough
Is this what you do with eternity?
Phil doesn't stay stuck in his new world
He's eventually granted freedom by whoever is running the cosmic game
He's playing
It's so beautiful
But not just when he's accepted his absurd life. His freedom comes only once he's personally transformed
The moral of the story here is clear: virtuous selfless living is necessary to find true happiness
And freedom. In groundhog day
There is some kind of ethical judge which renders the universe not meaningless
And not like our world as Camus sees it
I'm a god. You're God?
I'm a god. I'm not the God
Palm springs deconstructs this by eliminating an ethical moral basis for escape.
I am the antichrist
I'm just kidding
There is no god
The character's position inside or outside of the loop isn't dictated by karma, fate, god or some kind of ethic
Instead it's just part of what Camus calls the formless chaos of the universe
Sarah and Nyles have a choice: to exit the loop or not.
Are you scared to leave?
What? No
Not at all
I just
Don't wanna leave
Palm Springs sees the world as Camus saw: without an ultimate ethical or moral judge
But it ultimately rejects Camus call not to seek meaning and to find happiness in accepting the absurd
Roy possibly models the closest thing to Camus suggestion. At least for now he accepts his absurd life
This is always a good day here
You know
Sarah refuses to accept her new absurd life.
I can't keep waking up in here
And finds meaning in striving to overcome her plight
That was awful and crazy
It should never have happened
Putting her life in order and finding a way out, she is ready to move forward
Nyle's journey is a little messier
For Nyles, like Sarah, accepting the absurd isn't enough.
I thought I knew how to live
I didn't
Or I don't
But he doesn't find his meaning in self-development and striving to progress
Both groundhog day and palm springs end with a couple in a relationship
Groundhog Day Rita is Phil's object of attention early on but
Phil isn't good enough for her
And she consistently rejects him
You think i'm acting like this because i'm egocentric? I know you're egocentric
It's your defining characteristic
By the end Phil has realized he doesn't need Rita.
Well, where are you going?
Would you like to get a cup of coffee
I'd love to, can I have a rain check? I've got some errands
I've got to run. Okay
He's found meaning by living a selfless life instead of making her a goal
It's only then that she becomes truly interested in Phil.
Wow. I think you're a bargain
In palm springs
However, Sarah is where Nyles is finding his meaning
Take a look around
Whatever you're after it ain't here
Here I think the film is clear: Nyles finds his happiness inside or outside the loop with Sarah
It's really irrelevant to me as long as i'm with you
Phil Connors in groundhog day sidesteps Camus for another kind of
existentialist philosophy, In the face of an absurd world where his actions have no consequences
Phil is making a Kierkegaardian leap of faith
He chooses to live virtuously without knowing if it will ultimately result in anything
When he does this the karmic gods of
Punxsutawney let him out of the loop
Seemingly affirming his leap of faith. Kierkegaard would say that Phil by
acting in faith that his virtuous actions actually mean something
He's saved from his absurd life
Palm springs uses the sisyphean metaphor as a launching point for some fun philosophical meandering
But the answer it presents to the questions the metaphor brings up feel weaker to me personally than either Camus or Kierkegaard's
It's all meaningless, right? I mean
I hope it's not all meaningless
The best it can seem to muster is a lukewarm rejection of Camus acceptance of the absurd.
Cheers
To pretending not to care
And an affirmation that life, meaningless or not, is better spent with people you love 7
I can survive just fine without you, you know
But there there's a chance that this life can be a little less mundane
With you in it
But I think that's okay.
That's super low bar. That's a great place to start
While it's fun to talk about the philosophical implications of these two films
having a coherent philosophical viewpoint is not what makes a good movie
And to some extent by not giving a hard answer, Palm Springs reflects real life
It brings up some questions and provides multiple potential answers, but it's still up to you
How will you find meaning in the loop?
Special thank you to MUBI for sponsoring this video.
MUBI is an online streaming cinema with a heavy focus on curation
They have a library of international indian art house films that's available worldwide and every day
They add a new film with an explanation of why they think that film is worth watching
The film i'm going to recommend to you today is werner. Herzog's new family romance llc
The film is narrative fiction, but he shoots it almost more like one of his documentaries
It's an interesting
exploration of performance
Truth and lies and I recommend you check it out if you're a fan of herzog's work when you get your free trial at mubi.com
Thomasflight that's mubi.com
Thomasflight for your extended free trial as always. Thank you so much for watching and I want to give a special
Thank you to my patrons
Go to patreon.com thomasflight to learn more about how you can support the ongoing creation of content on my channel